welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and I am still trying to unpack
Loki season 2 one of the greatest arcs
of Marvel Studio storytelling yet and
even after breaking down this season
exhaustively episode by episode even
more details have emerged that I can't
leave this season without breaking down
for you guys everything from details
hidden in the actor's costumes in plain
sight to what was really said about Kang
in that TVA paperwork to even some X-Men
details that were confirmed by The
Producers so here we go U around 14 more
details that we missed in looki season 2
number one the latest new detail was
shared by kiwan in his Instagram in
episode 3 in the early seed on the loom
observation deck you may have noticed
that ob4 this scene only wears this
weird orange utility belt kiwan revealed
that this was called his data utility
belt by the prop designers and that this
thing opens up to contain a whole bunch
of gadgets and gizmos it was a nod to
his character data in The Goonies a
classic that I broke down on the Deep
dive Channel this past summer data was a
huge fan of James Bond and had A7 marked
utility belt that he would use to shoot
stuff out in this detail along with with
the appearance of his Short Round New
York Giants baseball cap from Indiana
Jones in the Temple of Doom in ad Doug's
Workshop in episode 5 just made this
whole season a love letter to KI Quan's
career next many are asking what
happened to Hunter X5 AKA Brad wolf whom
this series never really picks up with
in the epilogue but there is if you look
closely a little CIO by Brad on Mobius
desk in the final episode on the cover
of that jet ski magazine Brad Wolf's
actor headshot and its name are on the
cover of it so presumably our man got to
live out his life as an actor in The
Sacred timeline okay DET number three
since we are at this desk let's talk
about that TVA risk report threat
identification form that we have been
trying to make out describing the events
of Antman the was Quantom Mania another
shout out to Adam Burns for working so
hard to make this out with the help of
many across social media here is the
latest that we can decipher variant K
8910 name I want to say unknown and then
Alias Kang the Conqueror Branch 8911 23
10009 temporal Aura Kang variant Powers
not identified and then species Teran
and I like how they consider anything
from Earth to be Teran like they won't
say human they will say tan maybe that's
like a specific category of human and
then related case files and it looks
like uh 12 or so cases okay then down in
event summary you can make out the words
illegal apprehended use of energy
something with positively identified
Kang Tech whereabouts of suspect unknown
and then beneath that aura analysts and
then benath that investigation known
evidence and then in the lower paragraph
Just bits and pieces here controlled due
to the and then infested power and then
Scott Lang Ant-Man and quotes identified
then variant k89 910 leading military
involvement threat was neutralized okay
so from this we can gather that the TVA
categorizes Kang the Conqueror from
quamania as K 8910 there is an earth
8910 in Marvel Comics from an Excalibur
run in the year 1989 for what it's worth
1089 October 1989 was a big month that
was a month that we saw covers of quazar
Premier issue in the Marvel's film just
confirmed that the Bengals were quazar
Quantum bands so maybe there is
something there and that month was the
first time we saw Peter Parker's black
symbiote suit following the events of
the 80s Secret Wars in what if number
four okay detail number four one odd
detail about Mobius in this case File
scene in the final episode look at the
background as B15 walks through the
Chron monitor Bay to first talk to OB
and Casey Owen Wilson is completely
Frozen with his mug up near his face
it's actually kind of creepy like maybe
what he's reading about Kang the
Conqueror is freaking him out this much
or that somehow that Kang the Conqueror
is still able to freeze people in time
the case File did report quote
whereabouts of suspect unknown so that
Kang the Conqueror is not dead Okay
detail number five sylv's McDonald's
uniform first shown in episode 2 is like
everything in this McDonald's 100%
period accurate the production designers
worked with McDonald's Corporation to
get 1982 specific versions of everything
including the menu including that creepy
apple tree and that includes sylv's name
badge which has her name Sylvie and then
these five little stars these are real
life employee Merit stars that are given
to McDonald's employees from left to
right these stars are for cleanliness
teamwork Grill fries and good
personality okay detail number six
Loki's costume throughout the series
according to the costume designer
Christine wada in a behind the scenes
video that was released on Marvel's
YouTube channel said that all of Loki's
suits in season 2 were designed to have
curved edges to represent the way time
according to the TVA is curved I know it
kind of sounds like some nonsense you
guys say that I'm reaching on in videos
but the designer herself said that this
was intentional there's sort of no
squares or rectangles everything curves
just like time curves okay detail number
seven for L's final God of stories
wardrobe Christine W wanted it to look
like quot remnants of shattered armor
but not like real armor more like a
softer more humble suggestion of armor
so she used pleading to create folds and
such a way that the cloth was layered
the way armor kind of is and again all
of it is curved to reflect the curved
timelines she also singled out to his
simple loafers which he designed as a
statement for his more peaceful
destination on a throne anybody can pick
up an action figure to put on their
shelf but building a model shows the
world how devoted of a fan you really
are and if you're a devoted RoboCop fan
fan home has a model kit for for you
fanhome is a brand dedicated to
developing unique Collections and
buildup models from Universal Star Wars
Marvel and more a fanhome subscription
gets you magazines loaded with trivia
and stories about your favorite fandom
but also everything you need to build
your very own RoboCop Phantom's RoboCop
model stands just over 2 feet tall when
it's completed and has tons of awesome
details like a working thigh holster
silicone modeled facial features and
sound effects from the movie plus the
body is made from metal and ABS plastic
so it's sturdy and easy to show off when
the fan home subscription you get new
parts every month plus instructions on
how to put everything together so you
can build your model up bit by bit
rather than be overwhelmed trying to do
it all at once on top of that you'll get
a Robocop t-shirt hat binder posters and
a battery pack a fanhome subscription is
the perfect way to make your collection
stand out to get started just click the
link in the description below detail
number eight as I pointed out in the
breakdown Loki's reimagined horns are
made from the same kitsugi obsidian from
The Citadel but their long pronounced
silhouette May remind you of Thor's back
tattoo in Thor love and Thunder in which
she had tattooed RP Loki and since Loki
is now the god of stories and yes
co-director Aaron Morhead himself used
this term in interviews so I'm not just
making that up Loki as a rightful God
should have a seat in that omnipotent
City Chamber among the other gods or at
least have a kind of Representative
there at that Council just interesting
to read how the directors clarify that
they don't consider Loki a god of time
but rather the god of everyone's story
and he's the librarian that protects it
and allows it to flourish okay detail
number nine also just really cool the
way this episode this season and all the
MC really foreshadowed this destination
for Loki and It All Leads in one linear
path or one curved path but it did seem
like a destined faded end for him during
the Groundhog Day sequence when Loki
activates the loom room the automated
voice
says welcome he who remains welcome he
who remains now it is a programmed
response assuming that Victor timley is
the one logging in but it also
represents Loki is destined to become
his own version of he remains detail
number 10 furthermore it's Loki's
destination of a throne that has been
part of his journey since the beginning
in the 2011 Thor movie Odin said only
one of you can Ascend to the throne but
both of you were born to be Kings and in
the 2012 Avengers film Tony Stark says
you're missing the point there's no
Throne there is no version of this where
you come out on top and Tom hon to
prepare watched all of these scenes his
entire catalog of Loki arcs in the MCU
and reportedly it was his idea to say
this line I know what kind of God I need
to be for you for all of us because it
was a call back to his line in the very
first th film I could have done it
father I could have done it for
you for all of us no Loki okay detail
number 11 let's talk about Ren Slayer
she ends this series in the void and
headwriter Eric Martin told Esquire that
quote some fun inferences can be drawn
from the pyramid that is behind Rin
Slayer in the void background maybe Eric
Martin is suggesting rabona could have a
future with Pharaoh ramut ramut was one
of the earliest incarnations of the
character later Ron Tu Kang all the way
back in fantastic Board number 19 in
1963 but the big detail comes in Disney
Plus's close capting for this moment
that elith creeps up on her where the
sound effect description that they use
is written thusly metal creaking we see
that on screen in the Clos captioning
what metal creaking are we hearing for
this smoke creature could it be the
metal TVA emblem as a potential hatch
opening to save Rin Slayer from elith or
is elith a type of Machinery we know
Kate Heron and Michael Waldren in season
1 based alliance's look and design
partly on the smoke monster from Lost
and to create the smoke monster the
effects team on Lost combin sounds from
a number of sources including heavy
machinery clanking Eric Martin ponderers
does elith kill her or did they strike
up a friendship maybe elith remembers
her I don't know I think he remains
needed Ren Slayer to help him tame elith
and I think she could be a future deadly
force in an alliance with this Beast
okay detail number 12 quick detail that
I think I brought up before but I know I
missed it the very first time it came up
in episode 2 on the graffiti wall behind
Brad wolf in that London alley you can
see the words written all all M are
brothers and in an interview Dan delu
hinted that fans are free to draw
whatever meaning they want from that so
if we want to say there is a mutant
Brotherhood contingent in London in 1977
we are apparently welcome detail number
13 I definitely pointed out the HH
Holmes Hotel ad in the newspaper in
episode 3 as well as the insurance ad
beneath it but what I didn't mention is
the history that serial killer HH Holmes
actually took out life insurance
policies on many of his victims I mean
that was really considered his primary
motivator for his Killing Spree in his
murder Hotel he was both a Grizzly
murderer and at the bottom of it a money
driven con man okay D number 14 lastly
in the final episode when OB prints out
the second editions of the TVA handbook
as he flips through one of them you can
see the pages are blank this could just
be a production thing like they didn't
bother to fill those pages out and they
wanted kiwan to just face it away from
the camera but we just happen to see
some blank pages but I love the idea
that in this new TVA Employees are
encouraged to write their own notes for
ideas to make the operation better as a
whole to reference another famous Lost
episode tabula rasa the TBA is now a
blank slate where these prisoners
running the Asylum are free to remake
themselves the best way to support new
rockstars is to grab some Birch at nerd.
shop you can follow me on all social
platforms at eaos And subscribe to all
three channels of the new rockstars
Network thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
bye